what's so different about your literary
work is you started off with nine
different sort of characters and points
of view and then you expanded that to 35
yeah and there are days I wonder if I
bit off more than I can chew and where I
said around telling myself did it really
have to be seven kingdoms couldn't lie
couldn't I have been you know five
kingdoms five kingdoms would have been a
lot but but having thrown the balls in
the air I do feel compelled to to keep
on juggling him yes I use a point of
view structure in the books is a very
limited third person point of view so
each chapter is seen from from through
the eyes of a particular point of view
character and you only you hear his
thoughts or her thoughts you see the
things they see you hear the things they
hear so unless one of my point-of-view
characters is present at a particular
event or conversation or battle you can
only hear about a second hand or you can
only hear rumors of it that might be
distorted that's that's been the
structure I really of most of my writing
ID when I was a younger writer back in
the 70s I experimented with other things
like omniscient point of view or
first-person but and I settled on this
which I think is most effective this
this tight viewpoint structure
third-person and I think it's the best
way to tell a story because that's the
way all of us perceive the story you
know we we each look out through our own
eyes we can only hear what we're hearing
and we're not God to switch between them
I've never found the omniscient point of
view persuasive but with a big story you
know you you need multiple points of
view
I mean I'm writing the equivalent of a
of a medieval world war two so you know
let's say I was doing a world war two
novel how do you how do you write a
novel about world war two whose
viewpoint do you use do you use Hitler's
point of view to use Franklin
Roosevelt's point of view you can't tell
the story of World War two from any
single point of view you need all of
those points of view intercutting
between them to assemble a mosaic that
comes close to telling the entire
story and that's what I'm trying to do
except the difference being that in
world war two there have been literally
tens of thousands of historians who have
collected all those points of view with
King's Landing it's just you well it how
do you keep it how do you remember and
be able to adjust and reflect the points
of view and the personalities and so
many different ways you know I did wit I
have glibly said some interviews with
increasing difficulty but that's uh
that's not far from the truth it is it
is big I have charts I of genealogies I
have maps I have various files i refresh
myself I'm aided by the fact that I
think that my brain is wired differently
than a normal person's I seem to use the
brain synapses that normal people use
for real people for my fictional
characters so I forget real people
instantly
I will remember some guy who appeared
briefly in a book that I wrote 12 years
ago for people who are not familiar with
your work this series takes place in an
imaginary world there's a struggle for
control of the kingdom this dynastic
wars essentially one of three main plot
lines there's the other plotline
involving the other as he's sort of
superhuman characters and then there's
the exiled Targaryen daughter who seeks
the return of her ancient throne why
those three main plot lines well of
course the two outlying ones the things
they're going north of the wall and
Daenerys Targaryen on the other
continent with her dragons are or of
course the Ice and Fire of the of the
title a Song of Ice and Fire the central
stuff the stuff that's happening in the
middle in King's Landing the capital of
the Seven Kingdoms is much more based on
historical events historical fiction
it's loosely drawn from the Wars of the
Roses and some of the other conflicts
around the Hundred Years War although of
course with fantasy twist you know one
of the dynamics I started with there was
was the sense of people being so
consumed by their petty struggles for
power within
the Seven Kingdoms within King's Landing
who's gonna be king who's gonna be on a
small Council who's going to determine
the policies that they're blind to the
much greater and more dangerous threats
that are happening far away on the
periphery of their kingdoms and of
course you can you can see that uh all
through all through history it's a it's
a common dynamic that takes place in in
history you know the Greek city-states
before the birth of Christ you know in
fighting with each other squabbling with
each other even as Philip of Macedon
built up his armies to to conquer them
all but you even see it in modern times
you know the political struggles of the
India France under the the 3rd Republic
while the Nazi threat is rising but the
French politicians would almost rather
befriend the Nazis than each other maybe
there are lessons in modern day to who
knows I mean we have things going on in
our world right now like climate change
that's you know ultimately a threat to
the entire world but people using it as
a political football instead of you know
you'd think everybody would get together
this is something I can wipe out
possibly the human race so I wanted to
do an analogue not specifically to the
modern day thing but as a general thing
with the structure of the book